Hello, my name is Ann, so most of you who are receiving this video already know me.
We've had many conversations.
I'm your liaison here for full care at the Connors Clinic.
Some of you might be genetic only patients, so this is our first introduction.
So welcome to the genetic review.
So I'm going to share my screen here.
What we're going to go over is just a quick overview of how to look at the report
that you're going to get and kind of quickly interpret all the data, because it's quite large.
The full report is about 216 pages, and so there's lots of data points.
I'm going to just quickly run through what you're looking at, how it's organized,
so you can better understand all of these data points.
And then of course, when we meet, we'll go over the most important pieces.
So you'll understand the action steps that you will take based on the analysis.
Of the data here, so I'm going to share my screen quick.
OK, all right, so we'll move this down here.
OK, so this is what the genetic report looks like.
And as an example, you know, this is just one of the genes.
So each one of these dark purple headings is a gene family or category.
So the names of the genes are listed on the left side here.
You can see that.
And then we have this variance column.
So the variance column is really what we're looking at, the important factor
for where you have genetic variance or SNPs.
So we either have a one or two in these boxes, or you can have a blank in this box.
If there's nothing in this box, that means that SNP, there's no variant on there.
The gene is functioning normally.
If there's a one, that means you've inherited a variant, a single variant
from one of your parents.
If you have a two, that means you've inherited a variant from both parents.
So when we have these ones in two's in a family of genes, there's potential for
that gene family to not quite work as well as it should.
So you'll also notice here, this is kind of broken up into two different categories.
So we have significant SNPs, and then we have research and informational SNPs.
And so these top ones here are the most important ones.
They've been the most researched.
We know there's a direct cause and effect if you have variance here.
So we know more about these, the rest of them under the research
and informational category are variants or SNPs that we are still learning about.
So they are less important on the priority scale.
However, the whole gene family is important.
So again, most important or heavily weighted ones are the significant SNPs.
Lower on the priority scale are the research and informational ones.
So when we're looking at these gene families, you'll also notice that at the end
of each category, there's these little colored circles.
They can either have positive or negative numbers in them, and then there are different colors.
So here we see some positive ones, and down here we see some negative ones.
They are related to this interactive piece that we have on our end.
So when you get a PDF of this report, you won't have access to this
interaction piece, but it correlates to this bell curve here that I can click on.
So each gene family, the title of the family is listed at the top here.
And this is a bell curve that gives us information for you as the client.
So this is your line of where your results are variance for this gene family
where you fall in relation to the average.
The red line is the average.
So average is taking all of the data from everyone who was in this database
who submitted their DNA sample and their genetics have been analyzed.
So everyone, there's an average of where people fall for each gene family.
And then of course, again, the blue line is where you fall in relation to that.
And then this is kind of a color scale of the bell curve.
So this end here on the right side is the side for more risk or more variance.
The left side here is for lower risk or potentially no variance or very few
variance in that gene family.
So the color of those little circles relates to where you're falling
underneath this bell curve left to right side.
And then the number, whether it's positive or negative, is relating to how far
you're string from this average.
So the more you variance you have, the more your line is going to go on the side
of risk entering into this kind of orange and red zone.
So the more negative your number will become indicating more risk.
And then the opposite is true.
If you have lower amounts of variance, the more positive your number becomes.
And then your color becomes more blue.
So that's for each gene family.
So you'll notice that's like, for example, this BCMO1 gene.
There's two kind of quick glance risk assessments here with these circles.
And that indicates the risk assessment for the top one is for these significant
SNPs or variance.
So it gives you two risk assessments for this family.
So the most important ones here, you can see this person has more variance.
They've got variance in each one of these categories, single variance,
and then a double allele variant here.
So they're more at risk of this gene family not working as well as it should.
And then when you take into consideration the whole entire family is including
the research and informational SNPs, it lowers the risk because there's not as many
variance here.
So when we click on that bell curve, it's closer to that average less far to the right
or the side for risk.
So that's what you're looking at.
So these circles again are just a quick glance risk assessment.
So the closer your color becomes red, you know, darker orange or red, the more risk.
And then the more negative your number becomes the more risk.
It only goes to a negative three.
So a negative three is the highest risk.
And then if you're kind of neutral or in the middle right at the average, your number will
be zero.
So these ones, the, their, this person is right in line kind of with the average.
So that's what those color circles mean.
These metrics numbers give us an indication as to how common your exact genetic SNP variant
is.
So 44.3% of the people within this database have the exact same genotype or genetic variant
that this person has for this individual gene.
So it gives us an idea of how common it is to have a variant.
So you can see some of these are pretty common.
44% of the population in this database has that same variant.
Sometimes it's more rare.
And so we kind of weigh that with a little more priority.
If you have a very rare variant, we might need to take a closer look.
So within each category as well, there's kind of some scientific information.
So a general overview of what the gene does.
And then specific information over here as far as variants and things.
So you can read through this in detail.
So that is kind of a quick overview of what the report looks like.
And then also you'll get a full copy of this.
You're also going to get a copy of tumor suppressor genes, at least those who are in our full program.
So we also will look at individually based on your cancer and all of these different things
with our full plan patients.
We look at some tumor suppressor genes and some additional genetic variants.
And so you'll get a copy of that as well.
And then we also will send you general information that goes over each section of this report
that will give you general description of what each category is, why it's important.
So that's not specific to you, that is just general.
So it helps you understand what you're looking at if, you know, after we get done with our genetic review
and you say, oh, I can't remember what that BCMO1 gene is.
You can look at that general information and it will tell you, okay, this is a gene that's important
in the gut health section and here's why.
So that will be important.
So ultimately you're going to get this full report.
You're going to get a list of action steps.
So once I've analyzed all of this data, I put together action steps.
So some dietary changes to implement lifestyle changes to implement.
And then also some supplements that you can implement all with a goal of optimizing these genes,
these variants to help get everything in your body working better.
You know, for example, if you have a lot of variants in your detox genes,
we have specific nutrients or things that we can do based on exactly the variants that you have
where we can support the function as a whole to get you detoxing better.
So that just helps support the body as a whole.
So that's the goal of the genetic report is to optimize the genetic variants
so we can get everything working better.
Know that every single person has genetic variants, so we don't want you to be alarmed when you see
that you have these ones and twos, or if you're at a high risk for a gene family,
everybody has variants.
And so ultimately, this is a tool for empowerment.
So there's things that we can do to support these areas.
And so I'm just knowing where you have some genetic weaknesses, it's empowering to know
that there's things that you can do to support that and get your body working better as a whole.
So ultimately, that is the goal and we'll be going through this report and answering questions
and you know, we'll go from there.
So I hope this helps to just give you an introduction as to the genetic report and how you can better
understand it is it is a lot of data and a lot of information.
We don't expect you to know all the ins and outs of this.
That's why we kind of analyze it and put things together for you.
So there's also lots of information on the website.
Connorsclinic.com.
Dr. Connors has tons of videos on genetics and so you're welcome to do a search for
any genetic information and dig deeper if you'd like.
I hope this helps.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.